hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2019 American action
and thriller movie called Anna which
follows a charming and skilled female
government assassin who is working as a
double agent to gain her long promise
Freedom the movie begins with several
undercover American agents getting
assassinated in Moscow in 1985 one of
the women is brought in front of the KGB
director vasilyev he tells her he wants
to send her people a message which turns
out to be sending her decapitated head
to the CIA headquarters five years later
a man is scouting girls to be models for
an agency in Paris he visits a local
market and finds a beautiful girl Anna
selling matrioshka dolls she accepts his
offer and immediately travels to Paris
where she meets Dorothy her Booker and
her agency's boss John Dorothy brings
her to an apartment shared with other
models including Maude she surprisingly
already gets an appointment tomorrow
without any practice or training
sometime later the agency arranges a
dinner party for all its stakeholders
including the models mod leaves Anna to
get some food then she is approached by
John and another man whom John
introduces as Oleg falenkov one of the
partners at the firm Oleg openly flirts
with Anna Amazed by her beauty he asks
her for dinner and two months later they
make out at a luxurious hotel suite she
asks him to be more open about himself
to which he tells her he supplies
weapons to war-torn countries for a
living Anna then goes to the bathroom
retrieves a handgun attaches a silencer
and shoots him dead back to three years
earlier Anna lived with her
then-boyfriend pewter he was abusive and
aggressive causing her to find any way
to escape her miserable life
she attempted to enlist in the Navy but
did not hear any response Peter ordered
her to buy groceries then picked her up
but instead of taking her to their
apartment he put her in the back seat
with his friends while they robbed a
man's ATM Anna noticed cops coming then
she cried and begged pyoto to leave the
scene and come home with her the cops
chased them then their car crashed
entering their apartment Anna did not
notice a mysterious man Alex had been
waiting for her behind the door then he
knocked pewter unconscious he seemed to
know details about her personal life
then offered her a fresh start to work
for the KGB one year of military
training four years on the field then
she is free to go Anna refused and cut
herself but after he encouraged her to
put Faith in herself she stopped her
bleeding and accepted it back in 1990
Anna is interrogated by agent Miller of
the CIA regarding oleg's murder
she claims she indeed went to the hotel
as shown by Street camera footage but
waited in the bar and did not meet him
agent Miller explained that all security
camera tapes Inside the Hotel have been
erased implying that the murderer was
skilled he lets her go
six months earlier Alex promoted Anna
having finished her Academy to Olga a
department head at KGB Olga was
skeptical about her ability then gave
her a mission the target was a man in a
cafe but she would not tell Anna if
there were any bodyguards turns out the
gun was not loaded and Anna had to
improvise to hit her Target after five
minutes Olga left her even though she
completed the mission Olga taught her
that trouble never sends a warning then
handed her a new assignment she had to
study her new Target missing dinner with
Alex who harbored feelings for her turns
out the Paris model Scout was directed
by KGB agents to find Anna and Scout her
to Paris where she established a new
career as a top model
her actual Mission there was to
assassinate Oleg to avoid suspicion Olga
endorsed her to establish a relationship
with Mod
after assassinating Oleg Annie used a
body double to wipe the hotel's security
tapes after the CIA interrogates her she
calls Olga from a public phone Olga is
worried but she assures her that she has
not been followed then she tells Anna
that she will be going back to Moscow
Alex visits her and they make out she
then along with Alex and Olga meet
vasilyev Olga wants to assign her
permanently to her team vasilia learns
that Anna wants to be free after her
five years of service then threatens her
that no one retires from the KGB except
by death
disappointed she goes to Maude's
apartment in Paris claiming to have an
intense moment with her family then
Maude lets her take a walk
she calls Alex expressing her sadness
that she cannot get the freedom she
desires from the KGB
sometime later Anna has a photo shoot
job that is running late
she abruptly leaves the place after
threatening the photographer and then
meets Olga for the next mission the
target is a man named vortenberg already
waiting for her inside a suite without
any camera or audio devices so Olga
cannot fully monitor her she's inside
the suite for 12 minutes longer than she
usually takes Olga instructs her to get
back to the room to retrieve
wurtenberg's index finger in her
wristwatch which seems to be left behind
her mind seems cloudy so Olga advises
her to take one week's vacation with
Maude to the Bahamas after she gets back
she is refreshed and ready to handle any
missions satisfied with her performance
Olga flies her back to Moscow as
vasilyev wants to see her she secretly
makes out with Alex again in the storage
room before the meeting with Alex
getting out of the storage first at the
meeting vasilyev invites Anna to play
chess while Alex watches nearby he
notices Anna's suspicious hand movement
suddenly she takes out a gun and shoots
vasilia in the head
six months earlier when she took a
mission on wurttemberg Anna learned that
her Target wore a bulletproof vest and a
group of CIA officers had been waiting
for her Miller greeted her offering her
to work as a double agent in return for
her freedom and protection after one
year of service he had been targeting
her since he recognized the way she
holds her back
she agreed making her now under the
protection of the CIA during her
vacation in the Bahamas Miller came to
check up on her but she realized Olga
was still spying on her they met again
secretly and made out even after they
were back in Paris then Miller offered
her a job to assassinate vasilia since
he was threatening the respectful
relationship between KGB and the CIA
five years ago he murdered five CIA
agents who were under Miller's watch and
sent him one of the decapitated heads
since then Miller has been meticulously
planning vasilyev's assassination but he
needed a Russian to execute it he told
Anna that if she completes this Mission
she can have early retirement and claims
her freedom he even guaranteed her
safety by personally exfiltrating her
after the assassination Anna agreed back
to the present day after assassinating
vasilyev Anna points her gun at Alex and
injects him with a sleeping potion she
copies files from vasilyev's computer
and then escapes but Alex already sounds
the alarm Miller already waiting for
Anna at her supposed exit is driven out
of the building he comes to mod but she
claims she has not been in any contact
with Anna going back to New York he is
awarded his vasilyev has been removed
hopefully the cia's relationship with
the KGB will be smoother he then
receives a message from Anna telling him
to meet her at a specific Place turns
out Anna arranges a meeting between
Miller and Alex with both men backed up
by their respective organizations
she gives each of them information she
stole from both the CIA and KGB then
bids her goodbye both men accept her
farewell even though Alex needs to
process the situation Olga seeing Anna
Leaves From the security cameras gets to
her and tells her to not mess with the
KGB then shoots her dead the shooting
alerts both the CIA and KGB agents
causing them to assume attack positions
before leaving the place
three months earlier when Anna met Olga
for their routine checkups Olga admitted
that she knew Anna had been in contact
with the CIA since vortenberg's Mission
since she noticed cuff marks on her best
assassin's wrists she then told her that
no one else would know the situation if
Anna kept updating her about the cia's
plan when she learned that the
organization wanted Anna to assassinate
vasilyev she asked her what she wanted
the most Anna confidently answered
Freedom then Olga promised her that she
would get that if she did exactly as she
said turns out that even though Miller
failed to extract Anna after vasilia's
assassination Olga picked her up her
shooting of Anna at the park turns out
to be fake as Anna wears a bulletproof
vest and uses a body double to hide her
escape the body is quickly covered and
brought by paramedics causing Miller and
Alex to not be able to identify her she
hides in an underground tunnel changes
her appearance then Blends into the
crowd now free from her duties sometime
later Olga now appointed as vasilia of
successor walks into the director's room
and accesses Anna's database she
receives a video message in the video
Anna expresses her gratitude but claims
that she has recorded their last
conversation where Olga admitted to
supporting the cia's plan on vasiliev's
assassination she saved the recording in
case her boss did not keep her promise
just as she taught Olga smirks then
fulfills Anna's last request which is
deleting her identity from the KGB
database
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching